(alarm sounding in distance)
- [Voiceover] Warm out.
- [Voiceover] How long has it been?
- [Voiceover] Alright, good job guys.
Good job.
But I'm gonna have to
ask you all one last time
respect the drill, okay?
Fire safety is no laughing matter.
I can tell you all a
pretty gruesome story.
- Charlie, do we have to do this now?
I have so much work to do.
- You make us do this
dumb drill every month,
and every month there's no fire.
- Well hopefully a fire
doesn't break out, okay?
That's why we have to respect the drill.
- Harper, what are you doing?
- It's a long island.
I make one every morning, just in case.
- Smart.
- It's the middle of the work day.
- We're outside.
This is international waters.
Your rules don't apply here.
- Is that true?
- [Harper] Mm-hm.
- Charlie, I really need
to get back to work.
- Kalen, put your shirt back on.
Harper, stop drinking.
- Guys, please respect the drill, okay?
Alright, that's illegal.
Anna, Anna come back here.
You need to imagine that this building
is a flaming tinderbox of death.
Great, now I have to start...
I have to start the timer all over.
- [Kalen] So in international waters
I can do whatever I want?
- Oh, no, no, no, no.
You're thinking of diplomatic immunity.
- Right, like in "Lethal Weapon 2."
- [Harper] Yeah.
- How are we only getting worse, guys?
- Okay, so you're saying if
I die in international waters
I die in real life?
- No, I would never say that.
That makes no sense.
- Okay, if we don't get wi-fi out here,
I'm going back inside,
imaginary fire or no.
- Guys, please.
Respect the drill.
- Can we wrap this up?
Kalen thinks he's on vacation.
I'm afraid he's gonna take his pants off.
- That's it.
No, no, you guys think
this is all fun and games,
don't you, huh?
Well, well if you're not gonna respect me,
then respect the drill.
- Wait, you think we don't respect you?
- Is that what this is about?
- I don't know.
I just...
Sometimes I feel like you guys don't care
about what I do here.
- We're sorry, Charlie.
- Yeah.
We didn't know how
important this was to you.
We really appreciate
you looking out for us.
- Yeah, we um, we respect you.
- You're very important to me,
as an employee.
- Well thanks, guys.
Huh.
I guess I can get a little too worked up
about a silly fire drill, huh?
Well, you guys know to leave the building
when the alarm goes off, right?
- Yes.
- Obviously.
(keyboard clicking)
(louder alarm)
- I guess I just thought it was like,
cause there are no laws,
that men of like physics and biology,
and math,
like you could just add
whatever numbers you wanted,
and it just wouldn't matter.
- [Harper] No.